[Musique]
excusez moi madame nîmes c'est pas vous
après un prime time pour nous à nos
soins benneteau un peu du même vont un
peu le paranormal n'en fait pas trop
[Rires]
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
je vais me faire dubaï la nuit c'est
très très beau je vais vous poster des
photos c'est des délires de hauteur et
de démesure il ya une construction très
connue qui fait plus du 800 m un
immeuble
là je vais manger un petit truc l'hôtel
est très court il ya une baignoire
magnifique que je vais vous montrer
également ce serait bête
ce serait bête de vous priver de ça et
et voilà demain on va dans le désert je
crois et ça va être très cool
[Musique]
les émissions train de préparer
l'émission tpt people demain ça moche ça
bosse en bosse
pourquoi tu te filme toujours duo
d'enjeux pomme devant comme ça tu peux
ne pas altérer études je suis cette
année un filtre tu t'es bien filtre bon
si tu t'es bien filtres sont une
je la mette un filtre beau temps
quelqu'un qui est beau c'est comme
mettre une bâche sur une porsche sur une
ferrari
quel intérêt je trouve ça très bien et
ferrari mais tu deviens philibert vaki
medefi s'en sort quand c'est sûr que si
tu préfères un scénic à une ferrari on
va arrêter la cotation là pourquoi dire
ah oui j'ai repéré vulgarité mais donc
tu vérifies temps 45 ans et tu te fais
toi tu es faites ce que je dis pas ce
que je veux me fascine ça me fascine de
la gauche aille un cadeau pour tous
s'affairent gard gard at on va nourrir
mes noms auxquels c'est beau un
magnifique collier il fait beau à temps
qu'on le montre gens pour le mans salut
les amis on a un petit message vous
faire très important avec buddy on peut
dire on a un petit message très
important à faire c'est que 7 et 8
décembre place de la république et c'est
le noël des animaux organisé par la spa
est donc vraiment on compte sur vous ce
serait bien de passer là bas voir ce que
fait la spa et voire peut-être adopté
sait-on jamais une petite boule de poils
comme ça là robben comme c'est trop
mignon mais c'est trop mignon toile par
vous donneriez une seconde chance à un
animal et puis pour vous ce serait
vraiment du bonheur du bonheur du
bonheur je vous garantis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un gars ce parti ça oui ouais bon
refrain que sinon à bâle où ce qui est
glissé leurs fins
[Musique]
sarr de son lit c'est pas fini au début
à maurice
que de 15 petits points d'accord ok
j'arrête le beau
ça me rassure pour tp se verra que c'est
un grillage de son bénéfice net
alors j'ai un petit doute sur la
houppette du coup de maître pour qu'on
nous fait alors détruit ou des toilettes
normal
vengeance est un plat qui se mange froid
de la bravo tu les aimes le plus
[Musique]